Welcome, everybody. It's another Zoom call just a reminder. The only thing that's really new the last few weeks is that you can self schedule any follow up calls and if it's a follow up call, when you get to this screen, this is under our website and your member site.
Follow her. So if you see this and you click on the self schedule, you'll have the choice to schedule a Zoom call if you're going to go over. The only time you do that is to go over labs. Let's see if you were going to go over labs that you sent me or you had done.
Sometimes it's better to do it in a Zoom call so that you can share my screen. And then always make sure you fill out the follow up coaching call in full sheet. All right, first question.
Here's a new imaging technology. I just heard about the breast cancer summit sounds fantastic. I haven't had time to research it yet.
And it's useful as a detecting metabolic activity or if it's just a screening tool, that's much safer than a mammogram.
But here's the website. So others can get started. Other old research and if desired. If you've heard of it, please share what you've discovered. Well, what it is, I should have done a screenshot of the website. So you can see it, but everybody can go to the website. It's a new
ultrasound sect machine or you land a table at your breast kind of sags into this space so you get really a better three dimensional picture of what's going on in your breath. So it wouldn't be, it's not a tool to detect metabolic activity like a pet scan.
But it's a it's a safe, less invasive than a mammogram or a CT scan or a pet scan or or an MRI, even. And it gives you just a really nice three dimensional picture of a mass.
So if there is a lesion, a massive any kind, you could get a better picture of a measurement of it. So you know if it's growing or not growing, that's really the benefit of this tool. Now it's going to be years before it's really widely available.
It's just the way things move because some shirts, you know, a couple hundred thousand dollar piece of equipment that hospitals are not to add. If they don't see the financial benefit from it, it's going to be slow to add these things.
So, but it's a great tool. It's neat that there is some innovation because there hasn't been a whole lot of innovation in the imaging for a very long time.
Without going into too much explanation, I transferred some DMSO into a dropper model for easy application.
Once in a while, I get that bottle mixed up with my whole way of hathic drops and I put a few drops of the DMSO in my mouth by mistake.
Actually, I spit it out promptly since it tastes like liquid, you know what, must be the sulfur just, but just how stupid or dangerous is this at a scale of one to 10 where what is don't worry about it and 10 is that's perfectly fine to take orally.
And then 10 is that you have to take measures to ensure it never happens again and you're lucky you didn't die.
There isn't really any harm in that at all. DMSO has the capability of absorbing very quickly. That's why it has benefits to use it.
And the sulfur in it because it's diethyl sulfoxide what the sulfur does is works as an anti inflammatory that's why, you know, initially when the DMSO was created, it was beneficial for like the inflammation or, you know,
pain in your hands and, you know, like an inflammatory pain due to like an inflammatory arthritis or something and it can help bring down that paid the negative is is that the positive is is absorbed really quickly and it can help decrease that paid and by decreasing the inflammation, the negative is is that absorbs really quickly and it gets into your bloodstream really quickly.
And you, you know, the reason why I kind of kind of fell off the map of using it for inflammatory processes is because people tended to overuse it because it worked well.
But then that sulfur you get a lot of sulfur in your bloodstream and you actually can taste it so you can taste that garlicky taste when you overuse DMSO and people didn't like that.
Can it have any dangerous effects on the body? The only time it can have a dangerous effect when you have different defects that you, you, you, you tend to not be able to process sulfur very well.
It's a few people it's not very common and those are the people that don't do well with eating garlic or don't do well with eating onions because those are also sulfur compounds.
Most people are healthier eating onions and healthier getting more sulfur in but not everybody some people don't get rid of that very well.
But on a scale of one to 10 as far as danger and putting a few drops out your mouth in your mouth, it's would be a zero it's not dangerous whatsoever.
You are getting it into your bloodstream when you put it on your skin because it's absorbing so quickly.
There's no danger of course anything has some sort of lethal dose if you took the whole drop or a bottle of it probably still wouldn't be opposed to anything like that, but it does taste horrible and that's one of my kind of fell on a favor and using it typically.
No one can have some great benefits I mean you've heard of using MSM which is a kind of which is a supplement that's a powder it's not a liquid and MSM supplements can be extremely beneficial for people for inflammatory issues.
But again same thing it's a sulfur based compound and if you take too much of that you can get out of that car like he takes you have to take a lot of the MSM to get that but it's an anti inflammatory.
It's not going to hurt you it's not going to hurt your mouth.
You recommended a healthy mouth blend in my updated protocol it I noticed that it does contain some mint oils.
I'm supposed to not have mint within an hour of my homeopathic drops is there enough mint in this product that I need to make sure that I leave an hour between brushing with this and taking my homeopathic drops.
The answer is yes yes there is that same thing with any other toothpaste too if you have a mint flavored toothpaste remember you should not be using any homeopath within about an hour of that.
So mint spearmint peppermint can negate the effects of a homeopathic drop so you don't want to be doing mint a lot of changes you don't want to be doing mint toothpaste within about 30 to 60 minutes of taking a homeopath.
So just be careful of that.
Has anyone had any success taking oral B17 or amygdala possibly in high doses.
I should have pulled up a picture of this we have a number of people that tested tested well for B17.
We use the apricot our brand B17 it comes in two formulas what is a 500 milligram or capsule formula and what is a 100 milligram or capsule formula.
Now high doses depends on how you define that typically you depends on your weight but let's say your body weight is 125 pounds.
The maximum dose you'd really go is and you'd have to work up to this dose would be probably three to four 500 milligram capsules per day.
I know there's some clinics that go much higher than that but they typically do that for a shorter period of time.
Some people don't tolerate super high doses of B17 so I always suggest you start slow with a lower dose to begin with and then work up.
We've had one person and it was actually a staff person a number of years ago that took nine or nine or ten of them at one time.
I have no idea why they got a really bad headache and they felt sick and had to lay down and flush them with water and took about three hours to pass so they felt better.
But they learned a lesson not to overdose on that. It's very powerful and it can make you sick too so you have to just be careful with your dosage so you're not overdosing on that.
So now I'm done with the mastectomy and the reconstructive surgeries.
I want to focus on making sure that there's no reoccurrence in what order do I complete these?
Order complete wellness panel order cheek swab testing. Do it one-on-one consult with you.
I would do it in probably the stack order that you wrote that I would get this going right away order this get this blood test done.
Same time you can send in the cheek swab sample right away.
And then after we do the cheek swab testing unless there's things that you want to discuss before we tested put a new protocol together for you.
You could wait and tell you get that protocol back from me and then schedule the one-on-one.
It really has to do with the purpose of this one-on-one if you want to talk about it before.
Some people are like I really want to change my whole protocol cut way back or maybe have financial concerns or maybe they just want to change your life.
It takes as many supplements anymore or whatever it is that I could be a little bit more choosy.
You could write that on any specifics on your cheek swab testing form or we didn't know that too.
And then wait until you get that back and tell you might formulate some more questions to do on one-on-one consult.
Remember you could just schedule that yourself on that page on the member site or on our self-scheduling page on our regular website as well.
Again, that was the only question that we had come in when you said to have a lot of questions that came in.
So this is going to be a short meeting unless you guys have some more questions.
Can we measure the amount of glutamate in the blood? No, you can't.
So remember there's a difference between glutamate and glutamine.
The need is the amino acid. It converts to glutamate. It doesn't just convert to glutamate.
A glutamate just like any other amino acid is used to build proteins in your body.
You need to eat proteins in order for your body to break them down through the digestive process so that you can then absorb the amino acids.
And then your body can use those amino acids to make different proteins and enzymes.
So an enzyme is actually a protein. So you need amino acids in order to make those.
So you eat protein in order to, you know, obtain amino acids so that you can make proteins.
Now, you use them to make other things too. Glutamine is an amino acid that is also converted to glutamate on the GAD genetic pathways through the GAD pathways.
So if a person has some defects in those GAD pathways, they tend to convert glutamine to glutamate more readily.
And then it can be a problem. It can be with some people.
So glutamate is not a feeder of cancer. Glutamate doesn't, is it not a factor in the cancer picture whatsoever.
But glutamate is a factor in other things. Glutamate as a neurotransmitter functions as an excitatory neurotransmitter.
And in the brain, it can lead to emotional issues.
So people with OCD issues, people that tend to get fixated on something and can't get off of it.
People with anxiety issues have excess amounts of glutamate in the blood.
Now, again, why would a person have excess amounts of glutamate in the blood and in the brain?
Well, it's that they may have that genetic defect on the GAD genes and they make too much glutamate.
And they don't get rid of glutamates very quickly.
Or they may consume glutamates in themselves, not glutamate but glutamate.
So where would you get glutamates? Well, our food industry purposely puts glutamates in food.
Because it's an excitatory neurotransmitter. So that's the science of food.
So they purposely use glutamates like modusodium glutamate in order to excite your brain when you eat that.
So when your tongue encounters MSG, which is glutamate, modusodium glutamate, it fires an excitatory response to the brain.
It makes you think that that food tastes better.
Remember, taste is completely a function of receptors on your tongue that are firing back to your brain.
So that's why you can learn to like the taste of something over time.
It's a really a function of your brain.
So, but when you have glutamate on your tongue, it's going to fire an excitatory response to your brain.
And it's going to wake up your brain and it'd be like this like little firecracker in your brain.
And you're going to go, oh, that's good. That tastes good.
And you're going to want more of that food and you're going to buy more of that food.
That's why you'll be addicted to eating Doritos and you buy them all the time because they have modusodium glutamates in there.
Now, that damages your brain when you're constantly exciting your brain because of eating too many glutamates or having defects where you just produce more glutamates.
It can damage your brain. It can damage those neural pathways in your brain and basically burn them out.
That's the problem with modusodium glutamate.
It can lead to to damages in your brain and inflammatory processes in your brain.
And you know, microglial primed and antibody production of neural antibodies and autoimmune issues in the brain.
So, but glutamates really don't tie in to cancer.
Glutamine ties into cancer because it can be a driver, it can be a fuel source for a cell metabolic process.
But that's so much glutamates.
What do you recommend for carbohydrates daily intake with cancer patients?
So, you know, I wouldn't, you know, there are like adkins diets where you're really measuring your grams of carbohydrates on a daily basis and you're trying to try to get those grams of carbohydrates down.
And I guess you can do that if you want.
The, I would much rather have you just if you want to do that, much rather have you look at grams of sugar and measure that or better yet maybe because it's actually how your body uses carbohydrates that's really important is to measure blood glucose.
So, get a glucometer.
So, getting a glucometer and testing your blood glucose in a fasting state.
So, you're tested in the morning before you eat anything.
You have anything all night long.
You're going to have 10 or 12 hour fast and you do a finger prick and you measure your glucose.
The goal for a cancer patient is you really want to get that into the 70s.
So, I've stated multiple times that sometimes that's really hard to do but I have other members home page.
I have a monitoring sheet PDF that you can download and you can keep track of your glucose levels that way if you get yourself a glucometer.
And I have some information written about that that will explain it even more.
I'm looking at daily carbohydrate intake and rather have you more focus on getting your glucose levels down because carbohydrates are split into simple and complex carbohydrates and it's actually a sliding scale.
And then it gets even more confusing because there's a, let's call the glycemic index on how fast things actually break down into sugar.
And we've often said that you don't want to eat like potatoes and rice because it breaks down to sugar more.
But if you cook potatoes and you put them in the refrigerator already cooked, it becomes a more stable carbohydrate.
And then you eat it the next day the glycemic index is much better and it does not break down into sugar quite as fast.
So, it gets complicated with how you break it down.
It's not complicated and other and supplements that you're taking if you're taking burberry, it can help reduce blood sugar levels that help reduce that that glycemic load on your and prevent glucose from being too available to be used as a cancer fuel to so there's different nutritional things that make that difference too.
It's more complicated because if you're eating even sugar with a protein and with a fat, then you tend not to break that sugar down quite as quickly and you might not absorb much much and you might have a less effect on your blood glucose level because it's really all about not just what you take in but it's what how it affects the cell so it's it's really what circulated your blood.
Glucose is a better way to look at that.
I noticed the sedimentation rate is not an item of the blood work you have compiled at RUBA.
I know that is a blood test that nasha winters recommends for surveillance is that important to track.
If there are a couple other things that I do want to add to that test that I haven't done yet and that is one of them.
Is that really important to track not necessarily every blood test has a level of importance to track with that that has to do with the issues and I may add that to that test.
So if you want to wait a couple days before you order that maybe I'll get that done tomorrow.
I've addressed salary juice before my teen son struggles with acne and I began last began have began last week I assume taking it.
One time I used well washed non organic salary and within an hour he was very exhausted and I became extremely dizzy.
Neither of us had had anything else the disease is better but not God and I have extreme brain fog memory issues as well.
Would you think this is a reaction to metals or pesticides or something else in that salary.
If not then what if so what should we do also are you aware if salary juice has been effective for cancer, acne or other morbidities that it is claimed to help.
So yeah it's really hard to say that your symptoms were a direct result of drinking that salary juice and it could have been something in that a clue gives us that both you and your son may have felt similar after drinking it that gives you a clue that it's a greater possibility that that was it.
What could have possibly been in a non organic salary juice that it could have caused problems.
I don't know that I have to look at the recent dirty dozen list if salary is often sprayed as a gardener I'm trying to think why you would spray salary.
With a pesticide because I don't think there's very many pests that bother salary however definitely if it's not organic they use different fertilizers to make it grow.
Salary is not a super fast growing vegetable so yeah it's really hard to know what could have caused that it could literally could have become dizzy or exhausted if that was the only thing you drank like you're on some sort of salary juice.
That's the only thing that you drank so Chrissy said salary is on the dirty dozen list so yeah anything is possible if it was if it's a sprayed with roundup or something like that if it's on the dirty dozen list that's most of the things that the dirty dozen list were sprayed with pesticides like that and herbicides.
Then certainly an herbicide could cause issues like that anything that crosses the blood brain barrier could cause inflammation in the brain if it gets worse is that if you already have a history of brain inflammatory issues meeting you already you had concussions in the past you already have no other things that have caused symptoms brain upper monitor type symptoms.
That would give you clues that you that you probably already know that you have some primed microglial cells or worse if you have done a Syrex array seven X which measures antibodies for neural tissue and it was and you had any positives of that then you then anything that could cause inflammation the brain is going to make that worse.
So it's going to take it could take weeks for that to calm back down how do you help calm that down if that's the scenario that you have to use flavonoids that we've talked about you know multiple times go back and watch the video called neuro inflammation it's on the blog if you just search neuro inflammation on the blog you'll see it's about half hour video that explains microglial private and the things that you don't want to do.
For that certainly people that are more sensitive why doesn't everybody I know people that never eat organic foods well they might not be as sensitive to these pesticides and things like that they may have an intact blood brain barrier and or they you know I have symptoms of dizziness and lightheadedness and that's just normal for them so they never think about it.
I don't know there's all sorts of reasons for that but certainly if you have a damaged blood brain barrier and you're exposed to things like that they're going to cross that barrier.
Keto mojo sells a monitor that measures both glucose and ketones then we'll track automatically in their app monitors about forty five dollars I think app is free.
Yeah you can track ketones as well and we're talking back about tracking carbohydrates and you see it in glucomet or to track glucose.
You have to look at the cost of the strips because usually the ketone monitors the strips cost a little bit more and it just depends on what you want to invest in that so.
I just checked twenty twenty twenty three less dot on either dirty dozen or clean fifteen so it's not on the clean fifteen then you know that it is brain was something even though it might not be heavily sprayed with something.
Thank you guys for doing that work I had six ultrasound panels done on swollen lymph nodes in my groins armpits and neck looking for residual cancer last week the scans came back.
As oversized nodes in groids but the conclusion was benign in all well praise God for that.
The oncologist want to biopsy the nodes in the groin in the armpits if not cancerous the oncologist wants to do surgery of my neck and remove the lymph nodes as a precaution and to test them.
What are your thoughts? Well in one sense I would agree with your oncologist that well we don't know until we get a complete pathology report maybe we take the tissue out and spit it onto a slide and look for cancer cells there could be cancer cells there.
But what do you do to remove all your organs to do that same thing I mean you have to you have to draw the line somewhere or what how invasive you want to get so if not invasive tests show a low possibility of cancerous tumors there then I would be inclined to just say okay let's not to get to cut happy.
Easy your lymph nodes they can be so lymph nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with an infection lymph nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with a lot of toxins lymph nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with a lot of things that are going through them so what goes through the lymph nodes anything that's cleared out of the tissues upstream from that lymph node.
So things don't get cleared out of the tissues magically they have to go through your open-ended lymph papillaries so your lymph vessels pick up fluid and waste in the tissues and it drains down back to your venous system which then goes through eventually the liver again
and it's detoxified through the liver detox pathways so that's how we get toxins out of our tissues whether those toxins are from you know things that we're exposed to topically or whether things that get dumped from the blood stream that we ingested or or from surgical procedures that were distilled to that lymph node.
You know chemicals that you know chemical procedures like chemotherapy that have to go through that all those kind of things so I mean it's up to you I don't there's a lot of people in the world that they just will just do everything that their oncologist says because they won't they think that's the best chance to serve Iowa so they'll just go and have all those things removed and you know some people may I'm not saying some people don't have good results with that but there's a lot of people that have bad results not that too.
I think you have to make the decision to draw your line and have some sense of of conservativeness in allowing you know the next procedures.
The nodes in my deck where the tumors where have much calcification can you explain why and what this is so calcification of lymph nodes can be just the the nodal tissue up taking minerals and calcium because of protective measure of somewhat some sort.
And becoming overly toxic because they've been filtering too many toxins I don't fully understand the physiology of that I'd have to look that up.
Is there danger with doing biopsies only they said they would be small needles well there's danger of doing anything but is that less invasive obviously they're going to surgically removing it to test it.
I guess it was all nice and clean well now that we surgically removed it you can't put it back so yeah it'd be much less invasive you know you're talking about your invasive this what is doing nothing and what is next is doing nothing but getting tested on a regular basis the next would be maybe doing a biopsy and going from there so.
These are these are tough decisions when you know you're pushed in one direction so.
And you feel a lot of pressure in your decision making process but you're just going to stand your girl to go okay want to be wise about this and try to make the best decision i'm not going to just follow one person's advice by absolutely growing in the armpit surgical you'd be in the neck.
My original plan included a low history diet and then my genetics came back that I had an issue with the genes associated with histobines I have been on a histobines scavenger product as a result.
I wasn't given a DAO ACE DAO supplement though so does that mean I have the DAO enzymes for why would I have histobines issues.
So you have several gene families for histobines you have the DAO gene families and you have the HNT gene families and actually there was more racially discovered another gene family I can't remember the name of it I have to do with histobines DAO gene family was the first one discovered and that makes the DAO gene or DAO enzyme.
Then I mean oxidase enzyme that breaks down histamine now that is made only in the gut so you use if you took a DAO supplement so you can actually take DAO that's our.
Histoclear supplement is the DAO enzyme now if you take that that's not something you absorb that enzyme stays in your gut in that so it will so a person that would take the DAO enzyme is a person who has this horrible inflammatory process going on in the intestinal tract.
And they'll take that to calm that down for a period of time.
Another group that might take that are people that know that they react to foods that have histobines in it but they're taken as a precautionary measure because they're going out or they're going to eat that food.
And some people react to have a huge histamine reaction to alcohol per se but they're going out to a party and they know they're going to drink that you know gin and tonics and they don't want to have this huge histamine reaction so they take several DAO enzymes before they drink the alcohol or before they eat that food.
DAO enzymes do not get rid of histobines in the tissues and only would get rid of histobines that are produced in the gut or that are consumed by the person and and then spill you know have this inflammatory response in the gut.
So we don't recommend DAO enzymes typically to a person with cancer you're trying to get rid of the histobines in the tissues that is the HN and TG.
So even if you have a lot of defects in the DAO enzyme our DAO genes doesn't mean you should take that enzyme.
It's actually it's a pretty expensive product too so I don't really recommend it that often.
Histamine scavenger is a combination of different nutrients that help get rid of histobines in the tissues so and those are produced those are gotten rid of through the HN and TG not the DAO genes so that's the difference with that trying to get rid of histobines in the tissue.
You take histobines scavenger you take clear hist or you know or certain type products different things that will that will get rid of histobines in the tissues themselves.
When do you post zoom recordings usually within it gets posted within minutes it takes me it takes a few minutes to download the recording and then to upload it into YouTube so it's just as fast as it takes to do that.
I did check EWG before using the regular salary but didn't find it. I thought I've read that if it's either it's on either list it's somewhere in between possibly say yes that's correct.
In the salary juice book it says regular is fine if washed well I would dare do it again and remember to that you remember these fields that might be sprayed.
It's a tractor driving down the field and they have the scraping apparatus in the back that is sprayed and then they turn a quarter at the end of the field and you think.
The product at those quarters probably get like four times the dose you know when it's when they don't turn off the sprayer turn the corner you know what I mean it can be some weird like that that you just got a you know a stock of salary that was you know infested that's the right terminology with with some sort of toxin.
And if you went to the same store about another stock the next day you know if they're going through it that fast it can be completely a different dose I mean there's no way that unless you have your own organic chemistry lab that you're going to be able to test you know each piece of food that you're going to cook for your family to see the doses of glyphosate or whatever you're looking for in that.
So it's you it you're kind of hit miss and the truth is you can be exposed to the stuff with organic stuff there's cross contamination sometimes these fields are very far apart that they're contaminated with or it could be something completely different than it was contaminated with who knows or could not it maybe not even be the salary itself.
So oh there's another thing too you can actually have antibodies to salary so running the array Syrex array 10 I've had people that have antibodies to salary so they're going to have an inflammatory spot response by eating salary whether it's organic or not organic.
So that's a possibility or you could just had you know an inflammatory response because it's something else that was going on in your gut you know there's a lot of possibilities we don't want to completely jump to the conclusions that we were talking about so we just don't know everything.
As far as the benefits of salary juice yeah there can be benefits to juicing different vegetables but they just be careful going on a specific diet that's restricted other foods and other nutrients to your better off getting as many different foods and food groups in your system is as possible that's going to be the best thing to support.
Your biome and the rest of your biome is to have a variety of different foods so I've been told binders should not be taken closer than two hours how to either end other supplements do you agree yeah I think you should be taking binders on a relatively empty stomach.
Okay with that I think we're going to close tonight thanks for being on and oh that we're all prayed for you and hope that you're prayed for each other as well and if you do need any follow-up contacts make sure you just make an appointment alright bye bye everybody.